buenas tardes soy santiago y con mi
compañero ron vinimos en representación
del consejo de niños del mapa y hoy les
voy a contar cómo llegamos a desayunar
con el director de un museo les voy a
contar como prefiero dejar mi bici un
sábado por la mañana para ir a un museo
si escucharon bien me levanto algunos
sábados por la mañana para ir a un museo
al papi lo conocía era cosa de tres o
cuatro años atrás cuando me acerqué a
participar de varios talleres que
ofrecía para los chicos en vacaciones
fui arqueólogo por un día cocinero y
hasta el farero fui
a mí me gusta la emoción de montevideo
en general pero este es especial este va
a trapo porque sentí que estaban
teniendo en cuenta a los niños un museo
que tenga en cuenta a los niños
por allá en el 2016 mi mamá me trajo la
noticia de que el mapa estaba convocado
a chicos interesados para formar parte
de un consejo de niños un consejo de
niños
vayamos un poquito atrás para saber cómo
se llegó a este punto es decir cómo
surgió la idea de crear el consejo de
niños bien la inspiración del nombre se
refiere al consejo de ministros que
asisten al presidente de la república de
dónde surgió la idea
en el 2009 llega un artículo
periodístico publicado por el mismísimo
daily mail en el que resumió una carta
enviada por el niño sam poison al
national road music museo nacional de
ferrocarriles en la que el niño afirmaba
como los trenes y yo creo que puede
hacer este trabajo respondiendo un
llamado para cubrir el puesto director
las autoridades del boxeo con rápidos
reflejos no le dieron el carro director
pero crearon un puesto a su medida
director o fan director de fanáticos y
le comentaron la misión de aportar ideas
para que el national ruego missing fuera
más divertido y atractivo para los
chicos
entonces en el 2016 se toma esta idea y
se traslada al mapa y por el mismo año
2016 llega la primera reunión yo me
acuerdo que éramos muchísimos chicos y
todos queríamos participar opinar
sugerir mejoras entonces a cada uno nos
entregaron un carnet que nos
identificaba como un miembro del consejo
de niño
el mapa y me senté importante
bueno y acá llegamos al desayuno con el
director no me olvide periódicamente el
director nos cita a reuniones del
consejo niños donde sugerimos mejoras
proponemos cambios entre otras cosas tal
vez de este modo consigamos que el museo
sea más atractivo más divertido para los
chicos como nosotros
y aquí este es el punto para mí más
importante a veces los adultos no suelen
escuchar lo suficiente a los niños o lo
creen es muy importante sus opiniones
pero acá diferente acá la opinión de
cada niño es escuchada y valorada y eso
es lo que me gusta a mí más del mapa les
voy a hacer una pregunta a ustedes
porque creen que es importante que los
adultos escuchen a los niños
además bueno entonces le voy a decir lo
que yo opino para mí los adultos
necesitan nutrirse más de nosotros los
niños tenemos nuestras ideas como un
estado más puro
podemos expresarla sin miedos sin
temores sin prejuicios y etiquetas o no
nos han contaminado la mente en los
medios de comunicación los efectos
culturales negativos la política y la
sociedad también las etiquetas será
trabajo de los adultos hacerles los
cambios que se les tengan que hacer para
poder llevarlas a cabo pero yo creo que
el intercambio de palabras entre el niño
y el adulto al adulto
le dé más frescura y le ayude a
liberarse de la mochila de miedo temores
prejuicios y etiquetas que le otorga día
a día a la sociedad y al niño le ayude
en su confianza y su autoestima
volviendo al map y me puse muy serio
sigo participando en los talleres de
tanto participan de los talleres
sigo siendo arqueólogo de tanto en tanto
pero lo que me es más importante para mí
y deseo transmitirles hoy a ustedes con
esta charla es la posibilidad que me
brinda el mapa tanto como de ser
escuchado como de ser valorado y lo
último tanto como para niños como para
adultos los niños que quieran el mapa
siempre tienen las puertas abiertas
tanto como para formar parte del consejo
de niños como para cualquier esos
talleres y ahora hasta festejar
cumpleaños
muchas gracias por atención y excelente
tarde para todos
[Aplausos]